hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
the rumor mill has been in Full Tilt
recently it's been in full throttle for
a couple of weeks now and with a whole
bunch of new rumors coming into
existence and a whole bunch of old
rumors now finally being confirmed is
true like the Google Edition HTC one is
now true that was the inspiration for
today's video so today we're going to be
taking a look at the top 5 most
overhyped tech products in recent
history now some products live up to the
hype hype is not always a bad thing in
fact hype is often used by marketing
companies and marketing advertising
agencies to build up some attention to
the device or whatever they're going to
be releasing before it's actually
happened so a lot of commercials will
run and a lot of advertising campaigns
will begin before they've even really
started to finalize the details of how
it's going to be released so hype is not
always a bad thing and sometimes
products get really properly hyped and
that makes them more successful some
products though are just hyped up way
too much like they're hyped up to the
point where people start to form strong
opinions about them before they even
exist yet and sometimes the rumor mill
gets so out of control that it's just
impossible to live up to that much hype
these guys aren't necessarily the
biggest flops in tech history but these
guys are just straight-up overhyped
number 5 is the Galaxy Nexus this one
was set up to be the successor to the
Nexus S and of course the next Nexus
every year is really hyped up to be a
really important phone in the long chain
of Google products so this one was no
exception to that rule but it was
particularly hyped up because we got
word that there was going to be a curved
glass display which there is but if you
look at some of the sketches and the
mock-ups for this phone they were really
curved like very very curved nothing
like what we're seeing in the actual
model but we heard that it was going to
be curved glass so of course the rumor
mills went crazy and we got a whole
bunch of different mock-ups of this very
very curvy phone and there were a whole
bunch of different mock-ups also with
on-screen buttons and a whole bunch of
different other features we didn't
really know what it was going to look
like but we also got very very late in
the cycle a bit of a teaser that looked
like the side of the Nexus there was
also no word of what it was going to be
called so everyone referred to it as the
Nexus Prime what
was interesting because that was a
transformer and anyway you don't worry
about that but the Nexus was ultimately
a pretty solid product not the greatest
thing that's ever been made but it was
definitely a right number for is Siri
the long-awaited personal virtual
assistant from Apple now Apple tends to
get hyped up a whole ton and we'll see
more of that later but we always tend to
assume that Apple is ahead of the curve
in terms of technology and we kind of
sort of imagine things that are going to
happen from Apple that we don't really
know how could happen yet so when we
heard there was going to be a virtual
assistant and a voice-controlled and
voice-activated assistant we went
totally off the rails on the rumor mill
there were some star trek-like rumors
going out there and if you read the
articles from one seria wasn't yet a
thing you'll see a whole bunch of
different predictions for what we would
see in terms of functionality in Siri
now Siri didn't turn out to be all that
bad but it also wasn't all that great
and we're expecting to see a whole lot
more in iOS 7 when Siri gets updated
again but in the meantime over hi number
three is the Zune and now this wanted to
be really hard to believe but all you
have to do is look back seven years and
look at the headlines that were going
out and the Zune was rumored to be the
iPod killer it was rumored to be that
awesome product that was going to take
down the oh so popular Apple iPod now
yes this was seven years ago so
Microsoft of course was developing a
completely new product to do this so
they had every chance in the world
theoretically to do exactly that
but this was a pretty hard flop and the
Zune as we know was already discontinued
on the iPod seems to be doing just fine
so quite obviously the Zune was pretty
overhyped number two is the Motorola X
phone ever since Google bought Motorola
Mobility we have seen everyone try to
predict the specs of Motorola's next
flagship and they haven't made one sense
they've been bought by Google and
because of the incredibly large amount
of rumors that we've seen about this
next product we kind of needed a name to
call this phone and it was just dubbed
the X phone and now that's actually
that's actually the name of it not even
joking like that's what Motorola has
finally come out and said is the name of
this next flagship now that could just
be a codename just like we kind of code
named it the Nexus Prime but if you look
at more roll
website I'll include a link in the
description we literally have a couple
of paragraphs with every single thing
that is confirmed by Motorola about the
X phone and it really just says it was
made in Texas but you can read it
yourself it's it's a phone that's going
to be constructed and put together in
the United States which is a big deal to
them and it's a big deal to American
industry but yeah we don't really know
anything yet about the excellent and the
rumor mills will continue to continue
and number one the number one most
overhyped tech product and consumer
electronics history was probably the
easiest to decide and it's an easy
number one pick you may have even come
up with rumors about this yourself
before it existed
it's the iPad everything about the iPad
was rumored literally everything from
the name it could have been the isolate
it could have been the mac pad it could
have been the I tablet the Apple Mac
tablet there's so many names about it
and everything about the specs and the
form factor in the design and what it
would be used for and what it would be
good for what it would be bad for and
what it could look like and the mock-ups
oh my god the mock-ups you the mock-ups
were unbelievable you couldn't go a week
without seeing a new confirmed mock-up
about what this iPad or this tablet is
going to look like from Apple before it
exists because people knew that this is
going to be a product category and
people knew that Apple we're developing
a tablet but they had no idea anything
other than that so that's all we went
off of Apple tablet oh we already know
they have the iPhone we already know
that they have the Mac's so let's just
merge them into each other and make
mock-ups about it and call it a rumor
that's what happened big time it has
been blogged about for months if not
years the ultra-secret Apple device that
according to some in the industry is
going to change everything what exactly
is it might even make your breakfast who
knows about that right how about that we
don't know anything officially so
they've created these fake photos of
what it might look like there are
people's imaginings we don't know
anything officially yet but we're
calling it the eyetality we don't even
know what it would call don't even have
AI slate I travel exactly very expensive
and I can't have some numbers on that 6
to 8 or $900 predicting you can see what
we think we know here a 10 inch
touchscreen very thin the Brattle is
gonna have to shock and awe with this
one so you have to screen size the OS
the form
factor the name everything about this
thing was rumored big time and it was
still a very successful product that's I
think something that differentiates the
iPad from others it ended up doing
really well but the iPad was big-time
overhyped it couldn't have possibly been
as revolutionary as the news outlets
were making it out to be so there you go
that's the number one most overhyped a
crowd of shoutouts honorable mentions go
to the PlayStation 3 believe it or not
this was a hugely hyped product when it
first went on sale people were buying
this thing for two thousand dollars on
eBay someone was killed trying to get a
ps3 when it first came out okay so this
thing was really really valuable when it
first came out and that is a lot of hype
and to be honest I think the people who
paid $2,000 for it probably regret that
around now random access memories Daft
Punk's album I could say that a tech
product and I consider that very very
hype that was one of the most hyped up
music albums I've ever seen I mean they
use a very modern strategy but yeah that
was really hyped up album and BlackBerry
10 which was supposed to be the savior
for all things blackberry and we can see
how that turned out
either way thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this quick video definitely
leave a thumbs up below or leave a
comment if you have some other overhyped
tech products that I missed the
description below the like button on
this video is full of all your links and
all your images and silly mock-ups and
articles and things like that and that
will hopefully keep you guys entertained
but either way like I said thanks for
watching and I will talk to you guys in
the next video